professor hodgkin should be much better
known than she is scientists admire the
great determination and skill which has
always been the mark of your work she
was a highly intelligent highly focused
scientist
she would keep going whatever the
difficulties you just solve the next
small problem and eventually the whole
problem will crack involving what can
only be described as gifted intuition
she was a peace lover she believed in
solving problems by dialogue and not by
confrontation in recognition of your
services to science she's the only
british woman scientist ever to have won
a nobel prize for
chemistry
what was it about dorothy that made it
possible for her to achieve the things
she did at a time when so few women had
those opportunities
[Music]
dorothy was born in cairo
her father was very interested in
archaeology as was her mother
if there was a dig archaeological dig
she would try and join in she also had
this amazing ability for recognizing
patterns in symmetry and her notebook
show that from when she was really quite
young
when world war one broke out dorothy and
her then two sisters were brought back
to england she was essentially left as
the head of the family she had to worry
about whether there was enough money in
the bank account
her interest in chemistry had started
when she was only about the age of 10
when she went to a little tiny primary
school where they grew crystals and she
said herself i was captured for life by
chemistry and by crystals
so when dorothy was in her teens one of
the discoverers of x-ray crystallography
talked about this technique that allows
you to see where the atoms are in the
molecule and how they're arranged in
space and so she read about being able
to see atoms and said to herself there
and then that's what i want to do
in lectures she was extremely well known
for seemingly having gone to sleep and
yet at the end dorothy would ask the
most piercing question she clearly
wasn't asleep
[Music]
what personal qualities have helped you
in the work in some ways i suppose a
certain kind of cool-heartedness
going on doing things that
other people don't expect
it's quite possible to do
i think a lot of girls grow up with the
sense that they don't have the
permission to do things they might want
to do one of the characteristics that
dorothy's upbringing gave her was a
tremendous sense of agency when she got
married she was asked to stand down from
her fellowship at college eventually
this was changed and she also managed to
be awarded maternity leave she was the
first woman to have that at the
university of oxford it paved the way
for other women who wanted to have a
fulfilled scientific life and also to
have a family after dorothy's first
child was born she suffered an attack of
acute rheumatoid arthritis and left her
with distorted hands and feet as she got
older the arthritis did recur but she
didn't let it hold her back
[Music]
dorothy was very much engaged in
international issues and so she was
vehemently opposed to the war in vietnam
and indeed visited north vietnam
she did travel extensively and she made
a point of visiting first of all the
soviet union and subsequently china it
was the height of the cold war but
scientific relations continued and she
was always very keen to make contact
internationalism was a very big part of
her makeup
[Music]
doris remains the only woman scientist
in this country to win a nobel prize the
determination of the structure of
vitamin b12 has been considered the
crowning triumph of x-ray
crystallographic analysis the daily mail
ran the headline housewife wins nobel
prize the reaction of newspapers in the
60s whenever women achieved anything was
absolutely appalling
dorothy's influence on modern medicine
is almost incalculable all the problems
that dorothy chose to work on were
problems that would contribute to a
better understanding of the body in
health and disease
penicillin
the knowledge of its structure was
enormously important in the second world
war
[Music]
its structure was not understood until
she solved it it enabled doctors to use
materials that have been synthesized in
a laboratory and apply those to the sick
patients the way in which those drugs
are made now rely a lot on the structure
that dorothy determined
[Music]
she gave the impression to those who
didn't know her perhaps being a frail
old lady which of course she wasn't
there was nothing frail about dorothy's
mind attitude kindness
dorothy should be remembered for blazing
a trail really for showing that women
can be scientists and not only be
scientists but be extremely successful
scientists she gave to the world the
knowledge but also the way to do it the
determination not to give up if you know
and think you can do it keep working at
it and if that's not the definition of
exceptional i'm not sure what is
it
[Music]
thanks for watching if you enjoyed that
be sure to check out these videos next
and if you haven't already hit the
subscribe button and click the bell to
get a notification each time we upload a
new video